had a date last week a little date
watched a movie
with a gal and
she was a little younger than me she'd
never seen scream the movie
you know she knew about it this is not a
child it's an adult
it's a legal adult i don't date children
and i never have either
and you could write that down somewhere
and you could write that in ink
because that's damn facts baby you know
and
um
what's that talking about
oh she'd never seen scream and so
we're watching i hadn't seen the movie
in probably about 12 years or something
so we're watching it
and
it's just like it wasn't scary to her at
all it's not still i mean it was never
like super scary it was kind of scary
look some of it
some of it was kind of scary
especially in the beginning you know
when the ladies doing that popcorn and
he's on the phone and he's like don't
hang up
um
because the skit the thing that i
noticed she couldn't relate to was
she couldn't relate to just not having a
cell phone and not having like
to her it seemed ridiculous like why
didn't the person just use their cell
phone like
and that's it was just so much easier to
scare people
20 years ago
because that you had the
one you had to just the one phone
in the house
and if you didn't know have access to
that
that was a wrap daddy
that was that was the rapture
it would i mean you know it was just so
like
like if there was somebody gum coming
into your house you didn't have a phone
in your bed you know like
it just
it was such a uh
it was such a um
just a different time when fear there
was so much more propensity for some
real ass fear
now you got to catch somebody who hasn't
charged their phone and really
gas them up like that and dagger them
down or something or you know shoot them
with fire or whatever but back then baby
you could really
you could do some damage because
people didn't have that
they didn't have that access
to be able to like
get out of the situation or to evade
whatever the reality was you had to be
right there in the moment
and this was scary
and also like there had been the here's
one thing i did notice watching scream
the costume the scream guy that get the
scary person the murder
he looked like an
idiot
he looked like a hat like just a
halloween costume
because remember at the time like that
was the first time whenever whenever i
first saw it that was the first time i'd
ever seen it
so i didn't know that like this could be
a halloween you know like i'd never seen
it as a halloween costume
but this gal she'd seen it as a
halloween costume so many times it just
seemed completely ridiculous to her
and i just thought that was kind of
interesting man
how scary things become less scary
because
like things from the past become less
scary because they've been so like
commercialized or burnt out or just
overused that they've become almost like
a um like a meme in a way you know or
like a uh
like a popular thing type of thing i
don't know what i'm talking about who
cares
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you